[Musique]
une Jaguar à l'air
roulant une Jaguar à l'air roulant un
Flo à son
[Musique]
volant qui serit tout contre
lui qui serrait tout contre lui une
fille qui disait Johnny
on roule à près de
200 on roule à près de 200 laisse tes
mains sur le
[Musique]
volant une de chevaux qui
passait une de chevaux qui passait le
chauffeur
s'écriessait ma femme dans cette
Jaguar ma femme dans cette Jaguar et
comme un fou il
démar mais il glisse sur le sol
mouillé mais il glisse sur le sol
mouillé craque il est
[Musique]
désintégréouette c'est mon mari il y a
plus besoin de nous
cacher
il y a plus besoin de nous cacher allez
emène-moi
danser encore une fois les
copains une jaguire all roulant un
playboy à son
volant